hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his short
essay the crowd is untruth sir and
Kierkegaard stresses the importance or
if you like the absolute centrality of
what he calls the single individual as
opposed to the crowd when it comes to
truth of anything that really
fundamentally matters the truth of
intellectual spiritual and religious
matters or as he's going to say later
the eternal truth so not just truth in
terms of how many pieces of trunk I have
in my hand and at the moment which would
be for if I tell you that there's five
that's a falsity but four is a truth not
those sort of trivial things but the
truth that goes to the very core of
things and also truth you could say in
practical matters because he'll talk
about how truth plays a role for example
in our comportment towards our neighbors
now why is it so important that truth be
connected not to the crowd but to the
single or the particular individual
which seems kind of counterintuitive it
seems like you know instead we should
say well truth is what everybody agrees
upon
truth is what's objective in the sense
that everybody going into the same
circumstances gets the same result or
the same answer has the same experience
Kierkegaard says no that's that's one of
the dangers of the crowd you make the
crowd there by as he says the court of
last resort you allow the crowd to rule
and if you do that then truth ends up
needing the crowd he talks in the
beginning about two different views of
life he says there is a view of life
which holds that where the crowd is the
truth is also so the crowd determines
the truth that there is a need in truth
itself that it must have the crowd on
its side so that if something has put
forward as truth unless it actually has
the crowd or the many or however you
want to talk about it
agreeing with it ratifying it it's not
really truth Kierkegaard says that's a
mistaken point of view instead he says
there's there's another view of life
which holds it wherever the crowd is
there is untruth and if every individual
possessed the truth in private if they
came together in a crowd untruth would
at once be let in so one of the dangers
right off the bat is of losing our
bearings our point of view and taking
the crowd as being what is determinative
of truth another set of problems that
are associated with this that you could
see as both moral and pistola logical is
that as he says within the crowd as part
of a crowd an individual becomes
unrepentant they don't regret the things
that they do that they know are wrong or
the things that they say that they know
our false poorly you know you could say
poorly researched not well thought out
not well expressed maybe even just
fabricated on the spot they also become
irresponsible they're not responsible to
themselves they're not
to anybody else in the crowd insofar as
it's a crowd they may be responsible in
some sense to a leader within the crowd
but the leader can tell them that
everything that they're doing is a-okay
and they could believe it and within a
crowd the the individual feels him or
herself to have a diminished
responsibility if there's 30 people I've
only got one 30th the route the
responsibility for overturning
somebody's car and setting it on fire or
for spreading a bunch of malicious
rumors about somebody else or giving
this person the prize instead of the
other person who's more deserving I
don't feel myself to be as responsible
because we all did it together right so
that's another danger and that's a kind
of untruth on a practical level that
Kierkegaard wants a signal the other
thing that he says that's really
fascinating is he talks about a play
between cowardice and courage he says
that a crowd is an abstraction it does
not have hands each single individual
normally has two hands and when he is a
single individual lays two hands on
somebody is the two hands of this single
individual not after all his neighbors
even less the crowd but the individual
doesn't have the courage to do this by
himself he says the untruth is that the
crowd actually had the courage for it
since there never was even at the most
cowardly of all single individuals so
cowardly as the crowd always is every
single individual who escapes into the
crowd and flees and cowardice from being
a single individual it takes courage to
be a single individual to be accountable
to be responsible to say this is my
action not somebody else's they
contribute he says their share of
cowardice to the crowd and then the
crowd itself behaves in a way that seems
to be courageous it takes on dangers it
faces challenges
it attacks people who might otherwise
not be able to be taken on by the
individuals themselves but it's not
really courage it's sort of a cowardice
raised to a higher level and being part
of that is one of the risks of merging
oneself into the crowd forgetting that
oneself is a single individual now
what's the more positive aspect of this
so again remind ourselves that we're
talking about intellectual spiritual
religious matters Kierkegaard says or
the eternal truth we cannot appeal to
the crowd in this case we have to have
some other way of making sense of it and
here he talks about the single
individual as being the one for whom
there is truth there are so many things
within the realm of the spiritual and
the religious but also in terms of the
intellectual where something is required
of us and we have to make our own
decision about it we can't just take
somebody else's you know say so because
we're all part of this organization or
we're all part of this culture or we're
all part of whatever joining thing
you're going to talk about whatever club
you're going to call in this case the
crowd you have to decide for yourself in
a way Kierkegaard is taking the
Enlightenment and going even further
right dare to think dare to figure
things out for yourself don't just
simply rely on everybody else
don't canvass the crowd to see what your
opinions ought to be so that that's one
very important aspect of this he talks
about the the truth as being something
that has to be communicated by a single
individual now does that mean that you
couldn't like say have a printing press
or something like that of course not
Kierkegaard himself is writing things
out and
read what he has to say either in you
know print form or in digital form in
one way or another but he is
communicating as a single individual
saying these are my thoughts I take
responsibility for them and he
communicates
he says truth has to be communicated to
a single individual now does that mean
that he would have to you know parcel
everything up and you know here's a book
for you and here's a book for you and
here's a book for you no of course we
could have one book in the library that
we all read and it could be the truth of
st. Anselm or Aristotle or Marcus
Aurelius or whoever you like but we have
to appropriate it as single individuals
not just as people moved by some sort of
trend Oh stoicism is hot right now I'll
start reading Marcus and buying into
what he has to say
Oh stoicism is not hot anymore
Epicureanism I'll read Lucretius no that
can't be our approach to things we have
to be responsible he thinks if we're
really going to be taking on
intellectual spiritual religious truths
we have to be responsible as individuals
taking them on now he also tells us that
and this is a little bit more tricky to
make sense of he says that the truth has
to be communicated and received with God
as what he calls the middle term so what
does he what does he mean by that he
says the truth can either be
communicated nor received without being
as it were before the eyes of God does
that mean that you have to be in a
church no but that means that you have
to be holding yourself accountable to
something there's something bigger than
yourself to something transcendent
something that thinks that truth really
matters and further than further going
beyond that Kierkegaard uses the
Christian notion of God
not only being true not only being
interested in truth but being truth
itself here to talk about that relation
so he says that the truth can neither it
neither be communicated nor received
without God's help nor without God being
involved as the middle term since he is
the truth so when were appropriating
truth were in a way appropriating God
were also being helped by the truth to
understand truth and you might say well
that's a really weird way to talk
however if you look through the history
of Christian thinkers some of whom
aren't you know identifiable as
existentialist and aren't talking about
the crowd or anything like that you will
find this as a motif st. Anselm speaks
in this way and he probably got it from
Saint Augustine who also talks in this
way during you know dialogues the
teacher will say to the students great
example of somebody who is communicating
the truth as a single individual to a
single individual and we're looking at
as a third single individual they say
well maybe the truth itself will help us
to find the truth about this this and
this or the truth itself will help us to
find the truth about the truth so
Kierkegaard is actually saying something
kind of traditional within Christian
thought in saying that and the other
consideration to bring in truth is not
merely speculative or theoretical or
cognitive there is also an effective and
even more important conative that is
having to do with our strivings and our
desires and a practical aspect to it so
he talks about love of neighbor and you
might say well what does that have to do
with anything well he says to honor
every individual human being
unconditionally every human being that
is the truth and fear of God and love of
the neighbor to recognize the crowd as
the court of last resort in relation of
the truth that's to deny God and cannot
possibly be to love the neighbor and
then he goes on and he says the neighbor
is the absolutely true expression for
human equality if everyone in truth
loves the neighbor as himself then would
perfect human equality be
unconditionally attained everyone who in
truth loves the neighbor expresses
unconditional human equality so this is
a particularly important point it may
seem in in taking the crowd into account
that were being humane we're we're
loving our neighbor we're taking
everybody who matters into account but
insofar as we're treating them as a
crowd we're not because one of the
things that the neighbor actually needs
is a truthful relation to the neighbor
it may be that sometimes what you have
to do with the neighbor is take them
aside and say hey man you're screwing up
I'm telling them the truth about that
not simply going with you know whatever
the majority has to say or trying to you
know keep things nice and even because
we all have to be part of one big
cohesive group it may also be love of
neighbor requiring sacrifices on our
part to help the neighbor but all of
that is an expression of what
Kierkegaard here is calling truth and
this is where unconditional human
equality becomes a genuine possibility
at least as far as we can bring it about
according to Kierkegaard the last thing
that I want to say about this that that
Kierkegaard highlights in this is that
one of the things that we can often
forget is that a crowd is composed of
single individuals so he says because of
that it must be in everyone's power to
become what he is a single individual
no one is prevented from being a single
individual no one unless he prevents
himself by becoming many to become a
crowd to gather a crowd around oneself
to make the crowd central is to lose
one's own individuality or to use one's
individuality to throw that very
individuality away but at every point
there's still the bare possibility that
an individual could extricate him or
herself from the crowd and you know look
back at it and say no I'm not going to
deal with it anymore and become
responsible become probably repentant
and thereby to become what it is that he
or she is and should be the single
individual in relation to truth
you